thank you very much it is awesome to be
back here today I actually used to work
in this building and it's a little bit
about me I'm a consultant today I work
with banks of the mostly regional and
sort of all like very very rich banks
with rich histories I come here by the
way of Capital One obviously Amazon and
the PI data was also the original jet
chair committee of like PI that at that
happen here about two years ago so
that's kind of me being a egomaniac so
today what we're gonna talk about so
like I'm not gonna I think this is not
supposed to be a very technical talk but
the idea is to sort of go through the
thought process and and sort of to come
up with a few things that we can take
away that apply from a technology and
and from the open source adoption
perspective so why do we talk about AI
today there's a few things that have
happened explosion of data being one
which is like the ninety percent of
today's data was essentially created in
the last few years we also have the
advent and sort of the journey that
open-source has has has taken especially
in the scientific Python world there's a
cloud competing of computing and DevOps
as as emerging fields and to one quick
note on the on the infrastructure
automation and most of the banks that
I've been to I've never seen any place
which has achieved like better than five
percent hardware saturation so that
tells us that a lot of banks a lot of
hardware and it may not be used for any
any any analytics so combining all of
this we are you know we were just set up
to have a conversation of like trying to
build an artificial intelligence or of
your brain that can govern how consumer
lending or exhort to consumer banking
works so you know you know from a very
high level when we
but these types of reduced cases there's
you know a few things that that everyone
will come up with in the context of AI
everyone is going to talk about chat
BOTS do voice assistance there's
compliance and regulatory sort of in
shortage of intact the companies working
there for kyc know your customer ante of
you money laundering as model management
of regulations there then there's a
marketing of the decisioning bucket
which has credit risk you're sort of
rank ordering model personalizations
around who needs what and recommendation
it sort of just self-heal of those types
of decisions the interesting part here
which i want to call out and is the it's
a basis of my argument today is that we
have different types of use cases but
like a few of them of the non
proprietary and the other ones I feel
proprietary what do I mean by that by
non proprietary I I mean that any other
bank can to get this capability either
to build it themselves or to buy it but
it does not add to there's a competitive
advantage in the long term in the long
run the orange boxes are the ones that
are essentially being build upon by the
data that these banks have so your
customer data which is to proprietor to
the banks no one else has access to that
you can essentially build out these
types of you should use guess with them
so those orange boxes to me are the
competitive advantage while the rest is
sort of over time will just become
status quo so now that will just set us
up to talk about the banking data your
flywheel how does that come in and like
so what is that thing that the banks are
trying to do which can to benefit from
an automated intelligent agent so we've
just start off with data of the data
again we have a proprietary nature of it
and
of non-proprietary under the proprietary
side this is all your product level
information that the your bank may have
my customer relationship information
that hey I have a good credit card with
two capital one and have a mortgage with
cheese or other types of things or they
do all where do I spend a rider e things
that are there that are informations
that only the bank may have the Bureau
data anyone else can actually purchase
it so it's not it's not your competitive
edge that turns into analytics and
historically in your bank's a lot of
these analytics have happen from off the
shelf off the shelf side and so what
that means is that you can essentially
take it and and convert into your own
proprietary ideas around the unit
economics and segmentation and we'll
talk more about about these that this
the the next step becomes the decisions
and there you are such looking at
targeting which is something that that
you will that the bank knows but that
will hopefully give you growth and that
growth gives you more data which will
give you improved models improve
strategies and improve testing and we
cannot leave out testing because that is
another aspect of let which would make
us like this today the fight will churn
so now we have you've just set it up in
a way where we have this to growth of to
flywheel and would like an intelligent
agent to basically return this as to
fast as we can and like that becomes the
brains of our are sort of consumer
lending problem space similarly on the
analytics side the the important things
or the brains that they let that if
they're powering this is essentially
segmentations which is how would you
rank order two different types of true
customers so I am I as an example I go
to a Capital One comm apply for a
venture card and I get a line and an AP
are all of those things are specific to
me or or like I am
to fit some criteria that enables the
bank to let make that decision so will
like our point is that everything that
we are doing from an analytic side and
this to data your flywheel is powered
through these they just segmentations
and unit economics that the bank has and
these two things combined is that the
brain that you may need to automate or
to make it intelligent now we also have
some restrictions and constraints that
are not available everywhere else so
let's talk about some of them so as a
bank you are a regulated entity which
means that you have to comply with the
laws and acts so if you a fair housing
one as I go it's a big one
Equal Credit Opportunity unfair and
deceptive practices etc what they are
essentially doing is like making sure
that everyone is make it is the
decisions are equitable and fair
the second piece which is also a unique
to to the banks is the delayed outcomes
in my example if I get a credit card
with to fight a lot of credit line today
I mean that the bank may not know my
performance and they have to wear DMI
until you know there's some amount of
time that has passed so this is very
different than optimizing your
conversion funnel and retail for example
you still like you don't let you do not
know or like you don't have these
ability to like get the rapid feedback
so that means that all through your
system from a data perspective has to be
set up in a way where where you are
getting that long term feedback and
allows you to correct your business over
time governance essentially means that
that everything that you do has to be
auditable and it has to be transparent
hopefully reproducible
as well but we don't have to do have to
go there so what that means is that you
know going back to our original point
like we are trying to build out this
brain for this to flywheel and we have
some to constraints so now let's talk
about the actual you're building out the
brain part so how are how do you make
these types of lending decisions in the
first place so in and of two typical
your consumer sort of lending business
you would like to view your population
of new prospects which is which includes
everybody in this room would be from
from a perspective of the lifetime value
so to cost that it is to acquire such a
customer and then of your product terms
that are that you are you're giving them
so they based on these different through
combinations you will come with up with
a different up sort of criteria to
evaluate and then the criteria is is in
our example and NPV the net present
value all is saying is that you have a
discount and cash flow and you're
projecting it out and you are getting
some type of value and like this allows
you to have the differentiate if your
treatments across everyone so now
there's an interesting aspects that like
we have a grid but a 10 by 10 by you
know 5 and like we've come up with like
these number of boxes or what are these
number of different treatments we don't
have to be constricted to of a 10 by 10
grid as an example so you can actually
get personalized and like that's where
AI has this advantage that now you can
build out these types of decisioning
frameworks and these your models that
will allow you to make a much better or
more granular decision so in our case we
have the purple yellow end and red
you know should we should definitely
market the purple ones we may want to do
to the yellow ones if it improves the
scale of our business and we have we
want to avoid the red ones so like
that's sort of those unit economics and
like that's the that's the way you know
most most consumer lending businesses
have to look at themselves to be
data-driven and all of this stuff at a
typical bank is done with an excel-based
cash flow right so that you would
essentially have these you know nine
items and you have your business sort of
thick how the business works from from
the setup perspective and then it will
project out the value of a particular
type of a customer by the way this was
the sexiest way anyone has ever just set
up Excel Excel flying all right so now
we are you know we're not the fake if
human beings are the biological
bootloaders of of AI excel is the way to
do it all right and it's like you know
you basically to come up with this and
you will have all these excel sheets
like let's say at a big bank you got a
thousand segments and you're like
thousands of others decisions that you
are tracking every time you change
something and then you are also making
sure it is it is auditable as you know
to transparent and such so in this case
I want to save the two points there one
is that we have some kind of a
calculation that is meaningful to us to
understand the business the second one
is that it is an inherently human in the
loop type of problem so you need you
need humans input to either make sure
what we're doing is to fair or to make
sure that the proper inputs are provided
to the other system
so wool okay so now we are in this space
and like we have a lot of data we are in
the phase one where we we understand the
economics of our business now let's take
a little bit of Segway and talk about
the building data and through what is
actually the reality that is on the
ground so what I'm showing here is a
cobalt copybook which is essentially how
most of the building data that I have
seen it at all banks come in it's it's a
file format which is like weird weird
tricks and all of these things are
essentially going in intellect mainframe
so like that's the type of data that is
the most important one for you to they
get those unit economics because you
want to know how people are paying when
they're paying and then what type of
activities are they performing on your
product so if you're building data which
is again it comes from old-school like
if you if you have ever had a credit
card application and like that income
statement or that statement that you may
get is exactly what you see in a true
COBOL copybook and now you have to make
parse at all and like make sure it's in
some way that it's usable and you don't
have to make basically learn your cobalt
which I ended up doing earlier in the
year I did not really learn it but
whatever that means and if you are still
not like hundred percent like convinced
that it is the case I have to pulled
that last night this is software
engineer for COBOL and db2 and I think
someone up there made it may know all
the other ones but so sorry and it's
like estimated at like you know above
just six-figure jobs it's a real thing
that like banks are going through they
got a lot of technical debt on this very
important data that you absolutely need
to build out these brains and like all
that stuff is in COBOL with with like
null is actually like a zero or actually
zero like you know we're in outer
all right so we have you know we took a
little bit of segue we know a little bit
of our challenges now and we have a lot
of the data we are you know if you're
doing this these Excel models and we're
in a good place but now we have a lot
more data a lot more customers and we
want to get more sophisticated with our
unit economics model so what's the
second phase now we go to the model
based systems and in this case what
we're trying to build is a system that
is still you know the govern and the
transparent but all of its inputs are
provided by the model so our good model
is the ground truth truth for that
system to implement to you know come up
with the with the output value of of
segments so going back to that at excel
sheet okay so how do we do that how do
we make this more scientific and the
better from make a to data perspective
and then get more granular to - they
have better operational scale so this
excel sheet if you think about each of
its just cell it's essentially some kind
of calculation that is dependent on I
like something else and there's some you
know to draw input it will look like
something like this right so that you
will somehow you have like you know
empirical drivers the blue boxes or the
blue nodes which are your actual models
and then you will have some intermediate
calculations and you'll end up with the
total revenue and and expense that you
can add your marketing and then you will
get to this this like and your purple
metric that you would want to the
decision by and like that metric could
be anything it could be NPV it could be
rate adjusted margins and so on now to
notice that are the ground truth is is
essentially defined by these blue
empirical drivers and they would like to
model them so you once they're remodeled
we will essentially put that in and we
have this like giant excel sheet that on
each you know you little change
everything Reeve calculates but you know
we don't have to do it in Excel anymore
we can actually do it in a way that is
that actually uses our our abilities to
synthesize all this into data into like
nice models that can recover so like now
we are okay if you know if we got the
Excel model we got the brains figured
out where to you figured out a way to
like you know to provide these things
and they make it very data-driven
and you have some to data science like
problem the third phase is you're
planning an optimization so you have
basically done all this work and what do
you want to do now
so though in our system all of our
assumptions are explicit and they're
provided as models or as numbers you've
got take those and you have this like
unit economics calculator that it
defines your business and then you can
optimize up I actually use a scientific
alright nope up to studied optimization
techniques like ILP or or others to come
up with you multiple or if you're multi
optimization but a multi variable
optimization problem and so that
optimization problem is part of AI and
that sensitivity to gaming box up top is
your planning which essentially says
what happens if there's a recession
scenario what happens if our employment
goes up or goes down so they those types
of two planning and an optimization you
are essentially trying to build up those
problems and and express them as as a
just system that can actually perform
these optimizations and two based on
that you would show you would that have
some outputs through the decision
policies any of them historic data
you would have a need to make sure all
of your inputs and your assumptions are
actually safe and our whole thing so
you're going back to our data flywheel
what we can do now is that we can
essentially come up with a new
segmentation every time or if there's a
change in our to cost of funds or or any
of the economic variables we can then re
optimize and and have nutri decisions
and essentially make this process faster
and faster we did not make an an agent
that is autonomous and like making
yourself decisions but it is helping us
to build out these decisions in a way
that that is that is still governor ball
and there's some ethics and fairness
criterias that you can meet I think this
is a real just a dependency diagram
coming from a real world credit modeling
blog post and here is like is they cut
is that what these types of calculations
may look like at scale so you have that
state orange box up top which is or the
orange node up top which is your
original panels data frame and elective
that gets distributed out and you have
all these calculations of these
variables and that you are essentially
then gonna get synthesize out to a
smaller output but this in itself is the
just system that you have to build and
really understand very very well and in
order to operate it at that sort of you
know have some brains to to like run
your decisions so now we're gonna get a
little bit more around technology and
like why this is a PI data talk so
there's some critical observations we
had this excel sheet which is basically
a dag and we have humans in the loop and
we need to solve this problem you know
and we really want to be able to make
the system that expresses those two
constraints and there's also regulatory
stuff here as well so what this looks
from from a technology perspective is
that you may have some ax
to a cluster compute and like you don't
need a loss of scale today get started
but that has a raw data of death the raw
data is just like you know COBOL copy
books that you can then to convert into
ASCII and
and then that will convert into like you
know and then you can experiment with
that you have these tables built out or
you know all these drivers there's
something the collaboration and then you
will have a decision that is deployed
out all of these things and like this
holds your workflow is 100% answerable
through your PI data or of a scientific
Python libraries so we look at the your
first step of the task graph so with
tasks which is a parallel computing
library in Python if you guys don't know
about it please to check it out will let
your to provide you a way to like miscue
to define these calculations as as a
nice task graph and this task graph has
has properties around you can
essentially you know traverse through it
just sort of topologically and then you
know to get the actual dependencies
persist all across so desk has has that
answer of you know you're converting
your big giant excel sheet into this
calculator that can then be scheduled
from a local computer to a distributed
computer and it
it also takes care of some interesting
scheduling problems so it's like that's
the first answer the second one is on
the human in the loop and I've been
recently working with interact tools and
Jupiter hub anorak allows you or like
who provides you these a building blocks
that you can essentially take of Jupiter
or ipython compute environment and and
allow the people to play with that which
has awesome the collaboration properties
if just some ways the Jupiter message
spec is the new API for the data
processes to me that's an interesting
way to think
because you are essentially building
these like web apps with with with the
interaction and that interaction is
provided by the Jupiter kernel
so in Iraq tools and the Jupiter hub
will will essentially play the role of
creating those like your unique
workflows that you may need your so did
I have you workflows but to
appropriately capture that insight from
people from the humans in a loop and
then there's also like there's they
going back to where the picture if you
have a Hadoop cluster which is very very
often the case when I go into banks the
first thing is to like basis of library
called skiing and the Jim Crist had an
awesome talk on it yesterday which will
allow you to assess you work with yarn
and Hadoop technologies and then you can
use - - on top of it and that you can
have some - Jupiter and interact type of
you - workflows for collaboration so
that's the egg I'm obviously simplifying
a lot of these things but at the very
high level these are the building blocks
that you need in in order to to create
and maintain this brain that would let
you make equitable and more - profitable
decisions in the future so the two final
thoughts there are a few blog posts I'm
going to tweet this light out afterwards
and you know - please check them out
they have a lot more detail on how this
could impact your work so I'll give you
guys an argument where I made up a bit
of a leap on the jet technology and the
end the in the implementation side but
the argument is that we have a bunch of
calculations that have to be carefully
done and in order to drive these two
decisions they're motivated by a lot of
regulatory and compliance issues and you
then want to be able to build out this
system that can scale
and from a technology side we have a
smooth answer that is available in this
community any questions
yes so the question was that we do we
have delayed to to express this task
graph of could be abused futures for
real-time task scheduling yes are in in
our case we know our task graph
beforehand so it's not a dynamic and it
is not easy to change so you can just
use delayed but at but you know to where
you have real-time streams and like that
type of a concept comes in of the
futures is probably going to work I have
not used it because I have not had to
add to the deal with that example can
talk about the multi objective
optimization in basically how you got
stakeholder buy-in from the business in
how you validate that you're actually
you know taking some optimization
towards their objectives you know
balancing with everyone else's yeah
so the buy-in question was I think like
hey we basically wanted to provide
another tool and and like not that your
final answer
so this optimization result is not that
you will actually want to use but it's a
helpful way to make sure that you get
the business's judgment and and their
their intuition is aligned with the what
the data says so like you have to
essentially provide them lots of
different types of constraints and
different types of options which is
essentially how you will do game and
like you know if you look at scenarios
and like there's pros and cons in terms
of just setting up this it's an it's an
ILP problem because you have integers
that you are optimizing on your credit
line or your loan amount and your
constraints are essentially multi
variable so you are they as an example
you have a true constraint that each
cell that we saw in the end of Q is NPV
positive and you know less than X
percent of like other metric and
eventually it if you just solve our
problem like this is do plenty of
solvers who are which are available and
it capable of resolving that problem
pretty quickly
did that a great presentation thank you
how do you think about interpretability
of you know more complex models in in
the banking world yeah and specifically
both local and global both local
interpretability so every decision
whether a unit prove a customer think
that's relatively well understood the
global interpretability you could be
more challenging I don't know yeah so
the global one is is is exactly what
we're trying to answer from this this
system that I can perturb something in
as my inputs and then I have an output
that I can essentially you look at
across across like to various options or
like somehow surface the
interpretability here next to like are
your forecasting drivers itself your
forecasting column so you had a good
time series that you're trying to
forecast out so like in most cases I've
been able to get away with just like
linear should clear modeling the
techniques and like that's appropriate
for this because you want to kind of
make sure that that everything is
readable and take those weights mean
something to you however you can define
your segmentations and like every way
you can and like there you may want to
use some something more you know machine
learning or like less of the transparent
approaches and the two main criteria
that you have to be aware of is that
there is adverse action reasons that you
have to provide so that your make any
decision that your model is to creating
you can tell people why that happened
and and like that has to be expendable
so you could do that with your gradient
boosting machines you can do that with
the linear models I know some people
have as you tried doing neural nets -
too late you know to get to a place
where you can still get the end
unlike know what happened but it just
becomes more and more complicated in our
case we're generally happy with with
trees the sugary and boosting type of
techniques and then having the linear
linear regression for forecasting
problem the global impact of it is like
it's very hard to do without such a
system so like that's one of the one of
the ways how you will sell that is like
okay now you like change the model you
had one version do that you change your
whole system change and then you can at
least observe the outputs and then also
have some kind of trades to make look at
what happened we don't have a great
answer on the global optimization
because that's this just a hard problem
I have seen some to some people do
partially select Monte Carlo simulations
to like do partially known system that
you could do it because in our system
the way we define it is exactly known by
the models so do you happen to know any
bank that's using neural networks yet in
any like decisioning system I don't know
the bank I know a lot of vendors who are
well you know who are doing it I
wouldn't recommend neural networks in in
production for the most part it's just
too much pain because you may not get
the value back because and at some point
like you know your techniques are not
gonna add more than what you did already
has when you mentioned the the Monte
Carlo was that in relation to trying to
adverse action with some more
sophisticated machine learning
techniques so it's not for adverse
action it was more around you know what
happens if you make you book somebody
today you give them a bigger credit line
eight months from now how would that
system where like those those types of
actions will have it
hi I have a I'm here
hi I'm here I have a question about you
talk about like multiple variable
optimization so those who are opposed
our discourse value or continuous
variables like for example will be aim
to Dolf like credit line will you be
just like 800 1000 1200 or it's actually
a range of like continues 500 to 2,000
like or 10,000 it will be discrete
but like a reality even if you just use
the range your answer will be very very
close
so I don't exactly know how much of a
value do you actually get to get the
exact answer but it is a discrete
problem so if you want to just solve it
that way you use you have to use integer
linear programming to they get the
optimization so in besides credit line
like what about like APR or their things
or all these great values and how close
are the you know the intervals like folk
sample credit line because I just had a
very weird experience with a max card I
called a like or chase now before they
always have this very wrong the quality
of line like 2,000 or 3,000 but now they
gave like 2200 so what is like the
intervals right now was like the big
companies you're you worked with like
the interval of your credit lines yeah
because I think that's mostly your
governed by like how your operations are
set up like I've never seen a constrain
you know we usually try to keep you know
a nice round of round numbers but I have
not seen where we have like 20 to 50
credit line or something like that
but I have seen
weird numbers every once in a while yeah
because when I got those credit line I
saw the model is more like continuous
variable input rather than this great
but that's where my question come from
so your linear model would take those
two continuous input so that that's the
drivers but when you are trying to pick
a line you would want to pick the exact
line so that's on the optimization side
we can talk more effort okay thanks
cool thank you so much
[Applause]